Europe series of debates
it has been over one year since Russia
launched its full-scale military
invasion of independent and Sovereign
Ukraine
to a democratic Belarus dear colleagues
we have already witnessed our Union
becoming stronger and more resilient
facing these challenges together has
made us more united
and in this time of global instability
we need to speed up investment in Europe
to put our economy back on a stable path
of growth president your push for a
long-term competitiveness strategy an
ambitious trade policy and boosting
conditions for investment has been
Central to this vision of a better more
prosperous Europe dear president the
floor is yours
thank you
foreign
of the European Parliament
honorable honorable members of the
European Parliament dear fellow
Europeans
I'm delighted to have this opportunity
to contribute to this inspiring debate
here in the European Parliament
the most important political forum for
addressing fundamental issues about the
past
the present and the future of a United
Europe
I would like to dedicate my speech today
to the idea of Europe Europe that unites
us and gives us strength in the face of
multiple crises
today I'll talk about the need to be
Resolute in the pursuit of our goals and
to stand up for what we Europeans
treasure and value most
I will talk about supporting Ukraine
about Ukraine's place in Europe
about the importance of remembering our
past and the grave challenges Europe is
facing today
I come here just a few days after this
yenya celebrated the restoration of its
independence
what I'm about to say has been defined
at least in part by Luciano's
perspective
shaped in the long course of history
on the east shore of the Baltic Sea
where different cultures interacted
competed and enriched one another over
the centuries
although clashes between a powerful
forces of History often led to painful
tragedies they also engraved in our
hearts and Minds The enduring value of
freedom and human dignity
it is symbolic that 700 years ago
the ruler of Lithuania gediminas sent
out letters to his European
contemporaries inviting foreign Knights
Merchants Craftsmen Farmers priests and
monks to come to Lithuania where he
promised to that they'll be able to
practice their Christian faith freely
and to build a better life
it is this date the 25th of January the
1323 that marks the beginning of the
history of our Capital Vilnius
but just as important is that the
letters of getting us have anchored in
our political memory the vision of
Luciana as an open tolerant and
Progressive European nation they deal
that we are determined to pursue
indeed Louisiana has always been an
integral part of Europe and even when we
Face the most terrible ordeals
occupations and Terror we have cherished
this vital Bond
during The Long Dark Hours of occupation
Our Hope was kept Alive by the strong
belief that sooner or later we would
return to the community of independent
European nations the community that's
based on freedom responsibility and
trust it was this belief that on 23rd of
August 1989 inspired me and mo almost 2
million other people in this Estonia to
join hands in protest against the
illegal Soviet occupation and this
Stalin Hitler parked
we formed a 650 kilometer human chain
which were called the Baltic way
and this was the beginning of our March
towards Liberation and at the same time
towards our return to the European fold
and reopening to the world
today
I can see the same spirit that made the
Baltic way possible manifest itself in
Ukraine's struggle for Freedom
Independence and his Democratic European
future
the president of Ukraine and and my dear
friend at the European Parliament a
month ago that Russia is seeking to
destroy not only Ukraine but the
European way of life
to destroy by violence and lies all of
us who cherish freedom
honor and dignity who respect the rule
of law and human rights
we cannot allow this to happen if we
really care about the future of Europe
we must Take A Stand and Show by our
actions what is truly precious and
valuable for to us
this is a moment of historical
breakthrough
similar to the one Lithuania experienced
in January 1991.
when the Defenders of our freedom stood
bare-handed against Soviet tongues
armed only by boundless courage
today Ukraine is going through an even
more painful experience as it defends
itself against the bloody murderers of
butcher European and izume
I'm happy that Europe and other Freedom
loving Nations
did not succumb to the lies this
information and intimidation spread by
Russia
we stood United and extended
a helping hand to ukrainians when they
needed it the most
after overcoming some doubts we are now
moving forward with more determination
strength and resilience than ever before
a United's European response would not
have been possible without the strong
support and determination of European
Civil Society it is no coincidence that
a month ago president zielinski
addressed first of all Europeans
All European citizens
I believe that today most European
citizens understand that Ukraine's fight
is their fight is too in this fight
Victory can only be achieved through the
joint efforts of of us whole
this is
better I'm proud to say that as soon as
the war started it was not only the less
Union authorities but also our civil
society that responded to Ukraine's call
for help Luciano's assistance to Ukraine
including that provided by ngos
businesses and individuals stands now at
nearly 1.5 percent of our GDP
in May last year just in three days
lithuenians raised 6 million euros to
buy a combat drone and this February 14
million euros for tactical radars
Louisiana stands ready to continue
supporting Ukraine with great hope we
look upon the members of the European
Parliament because we remember that you
showed leadership on many an occasion
when circumstances required Europe to
take a bold clear and unequivocal stance
where to remember that 40 years ago on
the 13th of January 1983
the European Parliament adopted a
resolution on the situation in Estonia
Latvia and Lithuania
that condemned the Soviet occupation of
the Baltic states back then the European
Parliament was the only International
institution to react to an appeal for
help signed by 45 dissidents from
Louisiana Latvia and Estonia eight years
later immediately after the bloody
massacres took place in the Baltic
states with the kremlin's tacit approval
the European Parliament clearly
designated the actions of the Soviet
Army as military aggression and
intervention
I would like to thank the European
Parliament in particular for their
unwavering support to Lithuanian
prosecutors and judges who investigated
the bloody events of the 13th of January
1991.
as they faced pressure and prosecution
by Russia because they did their Duty
your support was of great significance
as it is the truth that Russian
aggression targets first Russia's
long-lasting campaign of spreading lies
in distorting history sets this stage
for its attack on Ukraine therefore were
first and foremost must stand up to lies
up to lies
ladies and gentlemen today we're all
paying a heavy price for failing to
learn the lessons of the second world
war back then as we rejoiced having
overcome one totalitarian Nazi regime
were overlooked and passed over in
Silence the site the crimes of another
totalitarian regime the Soviet regime
the fact that these crimes went
unpunished allowed the Soviet Union and
later Russia to glorify perpetrators of
war crimes ethnic cleansing and other
crimes against humanity
the distorted memory of the second world
war was eventually instrumentalized in
Russia and Beyond to justify the
atrocities committed today
if we want to avoid repeating previous
mistakes
we must remember them that's why
the
European parliament's resolution Adept
adopted on to on 20 in 2009 on Europe's
conscience and totalitarianism as well
as its decision to Mark the 23rd of
August the day once the day monster and
Hitler signed a criminal pact as a
European day of remembrance for victims
of all totalitarian and authoritarian
regimes have special revelance in
today's context
last July in order to counter Russia's
hostile behavior in the context of its
aggression against Ukraine together with
Estonian Latin polish and Romanian
leaders were called for a stronger EU
focus on European Collective memory when
designing educational programs for
school children as well as providing EU
funding to investigate and evaluate the
crimes of communist regimes at
International level
as well as the creation of a European
Memorial to the victims of totalitarian
regimes regimes in Brussels I believe
that all these matters would create a
link between the painful past and the
present in the minds of European
citizens
thus leaving less room for Russian
propaganda
ignoring the past is never a good idea
that's why Lithuania will realize that
remembering the crimes committed by the
two totalitarian regimes and their
collaborators makes us stronger and more
resilient it sharpens our resolve and
vision when facing off today's
challenges I'll be frank the first
reports about The atrocities in Butcher
and other places in Ukraine were
particularly painful to the people of
Lithuania as they brought back
memories of many butchers that happened
in our country in 1944 and later on when
the Soviet occupiers brutally imposed
the illegitimate rule where they
mutilated the bodies of slaughtered
Freedom Fighters and arrested mothers
who dared cry over the bodies of their
killed children
it's deeply distressing that this
unspeakable Terror has returned to
Europe
this makes it all the more more
important to ensure that Russia's most
recent crimes do not go unpunished
unexposed evil kept in silence year
after year not only poses a constant
threat to fundamental European values
but also prevents the Russian people
from confronting their own past
we must therefore break this cycle of
lies and glorification of criminals and
blatant aggression before it crushes us
all
it is not only the fate of Ukraine and
it's people that depends on it but also
any Prospect of a lasting and
sustainable peace in Europe
we must strengthen sanctions against
Russia till it stops its brutal war
against Ukraine and we need to ensure
that those responsible for the crimes of
aggression are held accountable
I therefore strongly support the
establishment of a special International
tribunal to enviously investigate the
crimes of aggression and the use of
Russia's frozen assets to rebuild
Ukraine
I believe that the resolution on the
establishment of a special tribunal
adopted by the European Parliament in
January will help achieve what's just
recently seemed hardly possible
ladies and gentlemen the European
Community which was created as a project
for peace is under unprecedented
pressure today
we feel more and more acutely that peace
freedom democracy and prosperity
can no longer be taken for granted
history shows that the most effective
way to expand the space of Peace
stability and prosperity in Europe has
been and will continue to be further
enlargement of the European Union
the successful EU enlargement in 2004 to
2007 and 2016 are testimony to that
the newcomers wishing for a stronger
Europe are enthusiastic about reforms
today too if we wanted to make the
European Union stronger
let's Embrace new members
with this in mind I warmly welcome the
recent historic decisions on Ukraine
Moldova and the Western Balkan countries
today Moldova needs our resistance more
than ever as it faces enormous political
and energy pressure from pro-russian
forces
we must also give hope to George's Young
Generation and civil society as they
actively seek change and a European
future
No Doubt
Thinking Out of the Box will be called
for during Ukraine's accession
negotiations
but Ukraine has already demonstrated
that it's capable of overcoming every
obstacle and staying firmly on cause for
reform
just recently hardly anyone could
believe that Ukraine could be granted
candidate status
as the war keeps raging on
sparked by the euromaidon Ukraine's
Revival must eventually reach its
ultimate destination in a United Europe
it's not only Ukraine that needs Europe
Europe two needs Ukraine with its
vibrant energy and its resolve to make
the impossible possible
that's why I dream of the day when
members of the European Parliament
elected in Ukraine will sit in this
chamber and the Ukrainian flag will fly
alongside the national flags of other
member states in the in front of this
building
[Applause]
the same flag that has become a symbol
of Ukraine's heroic heroic struggle for
dignity and freedom
desiena has heeded the call of the
European Parliament to mobilize efforts
and launch negotiations with Ukraine
before the end of this year it's
therefore crucial to ensure continued EU
financial and technical support for
Ukraine's European reforms
foreign
of the Baltic way in Europe
we truly wish to contribute to Europe's
Global Leadership
we aspire to build a world that is fair
and just for all a world that we will
hand over to Future Generations in good
conscience it is no secret that among
the greatest challenges facing Europe
today is maintaining a dignified and
independent stunts in its relation
vis-a-vis authoritarian regimes those
who want to weaken Europe undermine its
democracy and the foundations of the
single Market I'm convinced however
that we must remember that together with
our closest Partners we have been we are
and we will be incredibly strong
therefore if we are serious about
maintaining the rules-based
international order
we must not only take on the
responsibility ourselves but also
continue to deepen and expand the
transatlantic relations
we must fully cooperate with like-minded
countries in strengthening democracy
developing rules-based global economic
relations and promoting Fair competition
we must counter economic coercion
the issue of irregular migration
certainly deserves our joint Focus
the need to agree on legal measures to
combat
illegitimate migration and its political
instrumentalization has become even more
pronounced since Lithuanian other
neighboring EU countries became the
target of a hybrid attack by the Bella
Russian and Russian regimes in 2021
as national and local authorities
confront increasing pressure Solutions
are needed at the EU level
Lithuania fully understands the need to
properly secure EU external borders we
therefore support the targeted use of EU
funds
smooth return of irregular migrants
stronger focus on countering
disinformation in third countries and
combating humans smuggling and
eliminating the root causes of
illegitimate migration in Con in its
countries of origin
we need to look at the European Council
and discuss an important issue there
the preparation for Europe's green deal
and ensuring the competitiveness of our
economy there is a group of 10 heads of
state and government to which I belong
and we have written a letter
asking for a long-term strategy on
Europe's competitiveness
for us that involves strengthening the
internal Market
the technological and Industrial basis
and the bringing down
of barriers for good services and
private Capital as well as the promotion
of international Partnerships
and
clear
rules for trade we need to focus on
Africa
Latin America India and the Pacific
I also want to say a few words about the
critical raw materials Act
which was put forward by the European
commission this week these legal Acts
will make a contribution to the green
and digital transformation
so these acts will further Drive these
Transitions and will make the European
economy and Industry more resilient
Russia's coercion in the area of energy
have made it apparent that the European
Union is in a place to be resilient and
to make decisions swiftly
winter came and winter passed
and nobody in Europe froze to death
however there's been a hike in Energy
prices
which of course has affected the economy
as a whole as well as politics
we need to draw conclusions
and invest even more in green energy so
that we can become truly independent and
what's even more important is that we
protect our planet's climate
[Applause]
is the
I firmly believe
that lithuania's decision to forego
Russian oil gas
and electricity is an example an example
which other European Union countries
could follow we are very concerned that
Russia
is using nuclear as a coercive tool
what's happening in zapporisa
is a constant threat
could constantly
black out
this
power plant the biggest nuclear plant in
Europe
was
cut off from electricity because of
Russian rackets
I want to thank the European Parliament
for its full support
as we seek to prevent any further
problems with the power plant in
astrolis in Belarus and I hope that this
support will not go away the danger is
still there no in fact the danger isn't
going away it's even getting worse
because
Belarus
is planning to connect a second power
plant to the network to the grid we
can't allow a second Chernobyl to happen
of the European Parliament to conclude
and set the tone for today's debate I
would like to remind you that United
Europe was born on the ruins of World
War II
we have seen time and again serious
crisis give impetus to European renewal
there is something remarkable about the
ability of all of us Europeans to adjust
and move forward with unfaltering
optimism whatever happens
our recent trials have once again led to
reasonably fast precise and accurate
decisions each time he confronted a
migration crisis a pandemic or Russian
aggression
we made the right choices and most of
the time
we chose more Europe
which means quicker decisions
more decisive action and more resilience
I can assure you let Lithuania Bill
always work to be at the Forefront of
European decisions
this is our commitment not only to
Europe but also to ourselves
we know better than anyone else that the
risk of losing Europe means we are
making every effort
Europe to keep Europe strong and
resilient
we feel it is our duty to extend
symbolically the Baltic way so that the
whole of Europe can share the spirit of
responsibility that 33 years ago United
people between vilnus Riga and Tallinn
it is a task of many generations of
Europeans not just a single one you
contribute to shaping the future of
Europe
the all can and must work for more
freedom security and progress we all
have the responsibility to ensure that
freedom-loving nations in our
neighborhood are not neglected wronged
or forgotten
this is the Europe I believe in and I am
proud of let us be the co-creators of
such Europe thank you
thank you
thank you very much president now Saida
I will now give the floor to
representatives of the different
political groups starting with the Epp
group Andrews kubilus
Mr President
dear colleagues
I would like to welcome president of my
country in this house
which in the European Union has the
strongest institutional adherence to
European values of democracy human
rights Liberty solidarity and respect to
Dignity of each human being despite what
is his or her color of the skin and what
is his or her sexual or political
orientation
European Union will be strong if it will
be based on those values without
compromises if it will be based on those
values not only here in Europe and
Parliament or in some other EU
institutions but also in a national
regional and local level
this is the only way household's values
can be established also on the whole
European continent
why it is so important to talk about
those basic principles and values
because this is the only way how
sustainable peace can be established on
the European continent since there is
very well known law of geopolitics only
democracies are not fighting with each
other
that is why defense of those values
everywhere in our Union and spread of
democracy and basic human values into
the Eastern side of European continent
is the most important strategic
geopolitical goal for all of us and
especially during this war
we need to recognize
all of us in the European Union
who are not perfect back home in this
area there are things which we need to
improve and to strengthen
also in Lithuania
but today I want to elaborate on what
our president was speaking about
what should be our common strategic
agenda in order to assist the nations in
the eastern part of European continent
to enjoy the same European values of
democracy and human rights I want to
repeat
sustainable peace on the European
continent will be established only when
Belarusian and Russian people will have
a possibility to enjoy those values and
to live in a normal European conditions
such a strategic agenda will be
implemented only official proceed with a
very clear strategic action plan first
Ukraine needs to decisively defeat
Putin's Russia during this year and that
will be and that will create
possibilities for big political changes
in Russia and Belarus our most important
obligation weapons weapons weapons and
sanctions second absolute geopolitical
priority for you during this year to
start membership negotiations with
Ukrainian Moldova that would be most
powerful European geopolitical answer to
Kremlin hybrid offensive activities in
the region especially in Moldova and
perhaps also in Georgia set integration
of Ukraine moldovan possibly Georgia
should be concluded till the end of this
decade since that is the only way how
successful and prosperous democracies
can be created in those countries
success of those countries would be an
inspiration for Belarus and Russian
societies to follow
false Ukraine needs to get membership in
NATO if not during convenience Summit
this year than during Washington Summit
next year it would help Russian people
to abandon their dream to restore Empire
because Ukraine will be gone and fifth
EU needs to show clear perspective
Democratic Builders will have
possibility to integrate into EU
Democratic Russia will have special and
very practical relationship with EU we
lithuanians want to be part of European
Union which is able to implement such a
democracy action plan because this is an
action plan for sustainable peace on the
European Continental
thank you very much Mr
cup of the snd group
s
Mr President London president their
colleagues
fellow European citizens who are
following our debate Lithuania like
other countries of the same fate which
were destined to experience their
aggression oppression of Soviet
totalitarian Russia knows better than
anyone the price of the freedom one with
blood today in this place is Ukraine
which is fighting miracula for it and
our freedom it is finding the same
aggressor just with a different name it
is therefore not surprising that from
the very first of Russia's invasion of
Ukraine and up until now the voice of
Lithuania another Baltic states has been
the loudest calling for Urgent full
assistance to Ukraine also demanding a
United response from the European Union
in order to stop Russia's aggression
Here and Now
let me remind you that for years
Lithuania and other Baltic countries
have constantly spoken out warned about
the true face of Russia and the aims of
its authoritarian Putin regime
unfortunately not all members of the
European Community wanted to hear These
Warnings however These Warnings have
turned into a bloody reality for the
European Ukrainian people today everyone
has recognized that the Iranian Baltic
talks about the bloody aims of the
Kremlin regime was not just an
outpouring of historical grievances we
did it because we knew how fragile
freedom is and how great the cost is and
we wanted to make sure that this does
not happen in Europe again that no
Nation suffers brutal oppression and
assault on a territorial territorial
integrity and freedom ever
I will agree with the president
historical memory must not lie in the
archives history must not be forgotten
and the war launched by Putin is proof
of this once again I therefore call for
our responsibility unit and courage and
for the establishment of their Tribunal
for war crimes committed by Russia for
all possible sanctions and actions to
weaken the power of kremlin's regime
in order for Ukraine to win this brutal
War because that is a guarantee of
Europe's long-term security we must be
United to building and expanding our
defense capabilities our security as
Europeans will depend on how we work
together in a focused way to achieve
this because it's a strongly resilient
Europe can only be a Europe that is
United socially responsible just and
progressives
our aim as socialists and Democrats is
to strengthen the social foundations of
Europe to ensure that the objectives are
adopted at the Port Summit are fully
implemented in all member states a
social Europe must ensure that even
people with minimum income are able to
live with dignity and support their
families not end up in poverty that we
don't have any more poor children of
whom we still have over 18 million today
that men and women receive equal pay for
the same work that our pensioners
especially single women pensioners have
dignified old age and the rights of
freedoms of all people are predicted
only a socially strong resilient
responsible Europe will be able to cope
with major challenges such as green
transition digitalization which is
inevitable
inevitably will have impact on Europe's
social economic model and labor market
our people must be at the front rate of
all reforms let's be brave and United
for Europe half of the renew
no
thank you very much indeed president
on many occasions
in Europe
I think
we forget about
geography and sometimes we look at
geography excessively and we talk in
terms of north south east and west
sometimes we divide Europe according to
levels of GDP
but sometimes reality don'ts and gives
us a reality check and we therefore have
to look at the real significance of a
country the stature of our country
and this is something I think which has
happened recently we look at Lithuania
and we see that it is a great country it
is a country which has led the way in
terms of its position on Ukraine it has
been exemplary in its response in its
solidarity in its commitment in its
support and not only verbally not only
in what it is said but equally in what
it is done in its approach it has really
moved the
Global Community to give support to
Ukraine but it has given resources in
both financial and human resources and
it has welcomed many many refugees it
has shown that it is a great country
it's one of the big leading countries
because it has also
set an example which takes it Way Beyond
the level of its comparative GDP in the
European terms which is only
less than one percent of Europe's GDP
so now when we see at Lithuania we see
what Europe is it is commitment and it
is solidarity that is what is Europe and
what is your Europe is your country
Lithuania because at the moment of the
greatest of difficulty at the most huge
of challenges your citizens your
government your leaders have shown us
what the real true European values are
what Europe stands for what it
represents and it is a place of Refuge
it is a cradle of democracy but it is
equally a place where democracy is
supported with commitment with
generosity with solidarity but with more
even with arms if it is necessary
because it has got to be defended to the
hilt even in the trenches if necessary
and we have learned this from you from
your exemplary response and we have
learned thanks to you that we have got
to defend rights we've got to defend
people because it is certain that Russia
is a threat military and a due to
strategic threat and you have been
saying this for years and we failed to
take this on board we didn't realize
what being dependent on energy from
Russia was we didn't realize the reality
despite the fact that the smaller
countries who knew this were telling us
this time and time again
so you have shown leadership and I want
to thank you for that and for everything
else you have done thank you for being
here please pass on to your citizens the
huge gratitude of all this Parliament
and of the citizens of the whole of
Europe were the commitment to the
solidarity the generosity and the
Fantastic example which the wonderful
leading contribute of Lithuania has
provided for us thank you next to the
co-president of the green group Terrier
thank you madam president and first of
all welcome to the European Parliament
Mr President and most importantly even
if we are a bit late a happy
Independence restoration day to
Lithuania of course
more than anything colleagues the
full-scale invasion of Ukraine has
confirmed the need for European unity
and it is true only together as
Europeans we can stand up against the
brutal imperialism of the Russian regime
and we have shown here in the European
Parliament that we stand for unwavering
solidarity with Ukraine be it Financial
humanitarian Military Support Paving the
way for Ukraine to become a member of
the European Union but of course and you
have mentioned it Mr President the full
energy Independence of the Buddha
Russian regime and for too long
politicians also and especially from my
home country Germany have ignored the
alerts for from our Eastern neighbors
like for example Lithuania and now we
are paying a high price for this but
colleagues one thing has to be
understood simply switching from one
energy dependency on one dictatorship to
another will not solve any of our
problems nor does it shift from one
fossil fuel dependency to another
non-renewable energy source the only
sustainable answer that will prevent us
from having the exact same problem that
we have been facing in the last year
again in two five or ten years is to
make our energy consumption 100
renewable and that is possible and we
have no time to lose no country in the
European Union will manage this alone
only a strong European green deal can
make that possible and you are
absolutely right the green deal for for
long already has not only been a matter
that we need to protect our climate or
to stimulate our economy it has become
the most crucial measure also for strong
Security in the European continent but
Mr President and the fight against
authoritarianism does not only happen
unfortunately outside of the European
Union we also have to stay vigilant
inside because we can see attempts of
undermining our democracy of undermining
separation of powers rule of law and
fundamental rights in the European Union
brutal attacks on press freedom and
journalists and we cannot stay silent in
the European Union on these developments
because the EU is not only a community
of trade we share fundamental values and
if we want the EU to be strong and true
to its own values we have to protect all
our citizens from these attacks no
matter whether they are from Lithuania
or Portugal no matter their gender their
skin color or their sexual orientation
because safeguarding freedom and human
dignity means safeguarding freedom and
human dignity for all thank you very
much
thank you very much Miss reince can now
on behalf of the ECR group of Alder
Marto machevsky
president
today's war in Ukraine poses a threat to
International Security and it is a cause
of the economic crisis a lasting peace
is an overriding value therefore
solidarity is needed to get through this
difficult time
however there is a problem with European
solidarity today as some large countries
are pursuing their own selfish policies
the union is also experiencing a crisis
of values the values which once built
the community are unfortunately being
abandoned I say this above all to the EU
institutions where there is no
development of democracy and free
political thoughts unfortunately an
artificial balance of power is blocking
the development of Freedom acting
against democracy as the will of many
voters up to 50 percent is being
rejected
today's system is all about power at all
costs and the sharing out of positions
it is a kind of hijacking of democracy
the two main forces in this Parliament
the Epp and the Socialists although they
theoretically have different agendas
have for years joined together
immediately after the elections to
prevent the entry of a third force and
this way they do not have to deliver on
their programs the Socialists promise
social programs but fail to deliver them
they promised to look after the poorest
by but support CO2 trading which drives
up prices and makes people poorer
in contrast the Epp declares that it
cares about Christian values but does
not defend life from conception to
Natural death does not protect marriage
understood as the union of a man and a
woman and often supports gender ideology
which has nothing to do with true
Christian democracy
in addition both forces are imposing a
new an iron posing and EU Federation
which is destroying the Europe of
homelands which its Founders Schumann
and others imagined
unfortunately this artificial political
Arrangement blocks three thought and
ideas the evp's arrangement with the
Socialist does not allow for any
alternative a so-called third Force such
a system Fosters the political
corruption we witness in the EP
this pernicious and non-democratic
practice is also transferred to the
level of the member states even our
president gitanas now Saida is being
attacked and his election undermined
although he received 67 percent of the
votes this is not conducive to democracy
Europe is becoming through the Epp
socialist pact and in the ideological
vacuum it's in this array therefore in
the name of true European solidarity a
third or fourth force is needed to heal
Europe to restore its true Force based
on its roots
the ECR is the force that recognizes
this and wants to change the situation
as we recently discussed at the Summits
in Warsaw and Madrid we also talked
about the need to strengthen Europe's
energy Independence and to develop its
own industry including heavy industry
and defense
in line with this this thought today we
would not have problems with our defense
in times of aggression in Europe Europe
and the union need more democracy and
freedom based on Christian values a
traditional family and free thought
because that is the true soul of Europe
of the ID group Yak Madison
thanks so much Madam president uh
representative Lithuania first of all
I'm more than happy to be here as from
one from reporting States from Estonia
and I really appreciate your several
statements
has been together in history
and the good and also in the bad times
if we just remind the history it was
pretty easy for Russia to call it this
time Soviet Union but it was Russia the
same thing it was pretty easy to break
down each country one by one because all
those three countries eston Lithuania
had their own some kind of policy for
Moscow it wasn't very hard to have some
kind of deals each by each and the
result we know pretty well and it's just
experience for the history if you try to
make some kind of deals with a Satan you
are the loser in the beginning there is
no chance
to remind some kind of necessary of the
support Ukraine we all agree most of us
agree here
and there is a different kind of
ways to help Ukraine but the most
necessary definitely is military aid
as we can see in the news the next weeks
and the next months will be very crucial
in Ukraine because the both sides hasn't
won
and if somebody
saying that there is no winner in the
war
there is
the winner
can be only Ukraine because if they lose
we will be the next ones and there is no
question about that
as I look just on the statistics the
resources statista.com
those three public States
have given the biggest military and
financial aid Ukraine
Estonia with one percent let me read
0.98 Lithuania with 0.65 of the GDP and
the fourth one is Poland with 0.63
percent
on same time there has been very huge
help from the US and from the UK
but they can do more
and the problem for us now is that we
really don't have a lot yet
to really give to Ukraine but there are
much more to keep from the US from the
UK also from Germany and France
Germany has given 0.17 of the GDP France
0.07 of the GDP
those are just
gold facts and numbers
and now the question is that are they
really Brave
to make this change in the war or not
because if we will lose this momentum
now in the next months
we will face the new war in next two or
three years
so this is just the moment to think
which kind of chances we have
if somebody's talking about the peace
negotiations
the peace can be only if the conditions
are good for us and the only conditions
what are good for us can be that there
is no ambitious for Russia to start any
kind of aggression in next decades I
will not say forever I'm we shouldn't be
like very naive
Russia will not disappear but only thing
what we can do is just to weaken them as
much as possible and to show that they
can't win their neighbors
and finally I would like to really thank
you that Lithuania was one of the
countries two years ago who showed how
to deal with a illegal migration
there is no question that if you are the
war Refugee you need help
there is no doubt
but what we saw in Belarus it was just
illegal migration what was used by
Belarus for the hybrid decks and
Lithuania together with Poland just shut
down the border and said there is no way
to enter to the European countries
through those countries illegally
because if you open the Border there
will be no ending no ending at all thank
you and you did absolutely well so
thank you so much and good luck for
about the cooperation
thank you Mr Madison I give the floor
now to Dimitri
Health president you have the floor
Mr President of President outside I
would like to welcome you to the
European Parliament all political groups
have expressed how clear absolute
condemnation of the Russian invasion in
Lithuania in Ukraine
excuse me and your presence here today
is an opportunity for us to discuss the
future of the European Union what it is
that we have to do so that the European
Union will stop aging we don't want the
European Union's role to be weaker we
want the European Union to be more
effective in order to address the
challenges
and what our citizens want in order to
achieve all that we need the European
Union that will not only be a common
market and a little bit of a political
union we need
a strong European budget not only one
percent of the European GDP we need more
own resources we need more money in
order to reduce social inequalities in
order to support poorer countries and
poorer categories of the population we
want to implement the European green
bill
the European Union must remain a project
for peace and democracy
because democracy
suffers inside the European Union as
well in Poland in Hungary unfortunately
in my country as well in Greece
president I believe
you are not satisfied about democracy
being at its best in Lithuania either so
we must respect the rule of law and we
must avoid the risk of paralysis in
Council because in the council
unanimity becomes a weapon in the hands
of governments who want to Blackmail
others in order to achieve something in
their own interest
concerning enlargement we have to be
honest we should not promise to the
peoples of Moldova
Georgia or the Ukraine
something that needs many years many
changes and many conditions
enlargement
with the Western Balkan countries was
decided in Thessaloniki in 2003 and 20
years later the Western Balkans are
waiting for the European Union to
implement their commitments and of
course these countries need to make the
necessary reforms we should not repeat
the same mistake and promise something
that we cannot Implement thank you
Nicola bear
thank you
thank you madam president President Day
colleagues last Friday in Washington
Ursula Von delay in uh visited Joe Biden
without a mandate from the council the
president of the commission announced
our full alignment with U.S interests it
sacrificed our automotive industry and
promised an agreement on Rare Earth and
without any control she went along with
a dangerous U.S strategy of tension with
China of course there are historic ties
with the us but NATO
is a defensive Alliance but vital
geopolitical trade interests cannot be
aligned with Washington's we have a war
at our doors in Ukraine we need to make
sure that we have economic
competitiveness and that is our main
concern Ursula from The Lane is pursuing
a Personal Agenda in the hope to become
Secretary General of NATO in future but
Europe and its Nations need to stand
together and find their voice of
strength which is the only way of
guaranteeing Independence the the
council
therefore needs to put ursulf on the
lane in her place and needs to defend
above all the interests of our
incontinent the floor
to Ranger
thank you president Mr President now
said us
commissioner
I remember that in the late 70s my
father with a map in his hand
taught me my brother and my sister that
Baltic states were not Soviet Union they
were occupied and they remained
independent
and I remember that in 87
our prime minister from our party kavach
Silva that was prime minister 10 years
and president of the Republic 10 years
in 87 he had a huge conflict with the
parliament because he didn't agree with
a visit to Soviet Union where the
territories of Baltic states were
included and the government fell down
because he was defending this principle
so I have to tell you that during the
caves we were in European Union
defending the sovereignty and the future
of democracy and freedom to Lithuania
Latvia and the Estonia and today Mr
President we are very proud because your
country became the a world front-runner
of Defense of democracy of freedom of
Human Rights
this was clear
when you
sent all the support to the Ukrainian
people but also when you are claiming
for democracy in Belarus and when you
are saying that you don't accept the
blackmail of China
the example of the Ukrainian solidarity
I have to say shows that he wants for
other countries in Europe and are you
there to say in world the same fate that
Lithuania have that was
in a very very oppressive regime and
managed to become independent and to
give Freedom prosperity and human rights
respect to all the citizens and so I
would like to thank you to say ask you
Mr President to all the Lithuanian
people and also to you and to your
government and let me
try to invite you to hear to have here
your view or your say on the prophets
for Belarus and how should we shape our
relation with China because the
Lithuanian experience is a very
important one and can set the example to
all of us thank you very much
thank you Mr ranjel I give the floor now
to Dominic Ruiz the weather
president thanks very much Madam
president and welcome of course to the
president of the Republic the president
now said as I completely agree with what
you said in your speech your ideas of
being tough when it came to Russia
complete support for Ukraine in the
defense of its territory integrity and
sovereignty also the opening up of
possibility of enlargement for Ukraine
Georgia Moldova and the Western Balkans
I completely support this agenda at the
same time I would like to say that this
agenda will If we're honest if we're
going to be credible this agenda also
needs to mention something you didn't
mention the deepening of the political
project in Europe it should be clear and
I'm speaking as a spokesman for my group
when it comes to constitutional issues
the that there can't be um Enlightenment
without deepening we need to we can't
have a council of foreign affairs with
29 32 members which requires unanimity
to adopt the mff with 33 members States
and 33 National ratifications as well so
Mr President I would urge you to
contribute to the debate in the council
to open the way to voting on a new
treaty which is more democratic more
effective and therefore more Federal so
it was the verse I give the floor now to
maripier veteran
thank you madam president president
commissioners
one
needs courage
to support unconditionally the Ukrainian
people as Lithuania has always done and
you need courage to open your borders to
protect those who've fled lukashenko's
dictatorial regime you need courage in
the face of expansionist an expansionist
a Russian neighbor and you need courage
to a head of Chinese interests
and you need courage to not turn your
back on your allies and Lithuania
satiscarriage your population uh is
testimony to that and there are some who
fail to see that National sovereignty is
reinforced by European solidarity your
country goes to show what some of us
reject which is that greater European
integration is to protect our values yes
the European Union needs to Stand United
and that's why and you said this
yourself and a reactive instrument which
is effective is needed and should not be
blocked by one country it's imperative
that that is no longer possible we need
to be able to react and protect
ourselves when third countries seek to
limit our freedom president your country
and the lithuanians
have shown to Europe that the only way
to defend democracy and today's
challenges is to do what you've done
faced by a pie Dynamic we've acted a
group purchases of vaccines the recovery
facility but there's also been the
unjustified invasion of Ukraine and
we've acted sanctions Aid weapons Supply
there's been the energy crisis that we
continue to react as Europeans new
supply lines investment in green and
renewable energy sources
now
we need to continue to act as Europeans
and Stave off the Sirens of the vision
we need to reinforce the dialogue
between our countries and also with
third countries we need to continue to
act as Sovereign Europeans who show
solidarity we need to feed our citizens
and face up to the challenge of climate
change and we should leave no one behind
in order to achieve this we need to
enter into dialogue and act together we
in Parliament stand ready to do this to
take your way the way of your people to
make sure that these reactions and
actions are not without replying that
collectively we can meet the
expectations of all Europeans and Mr
President Nicola Bay my colleague who's
already left the hemicycle said nothing
about your country but please
assured that russondo National and
extremists will never win the day thank
you vedren I give the floor now to
run it
foreign
thank you madam president
your Excellency commission as dear
colleagues
president I would like to say essencia
thank you
for your contribution and your
continuous efforts in order to provide
the necessary assistance to Ukraine you
went to Ukraine on the eve of this war
and met its president you did not heed
the words of the heads of other
countries you said that we had to
provide all the necessary assistance to
Ukraine and I say yes sincere thank you
to you but I would like to see more
active political your more active
political participation in dealing with
lithuania's internal problems such as
huge inflation Rising food prices
increasing interest rates
uh some families are finding it hard
to uh to live I also would like to
mention the crisis in our Dairy sector
and the complicated future of our
agriculture
um we are not satisfied with the uh
National politics in various regions of
Lithuania since there is a huge gap
between uh the level of living in rural
areas and in towns I understand that the
war in Ukraine has
has
widened all these problems however it
would be it would not be correct to
start doubting now
we need to take the course of action in
order to ensure better level of living
for all thank you thank you Mr Robin
next is
Mr President ladies and gentlemen
it was a very important speech and I
regret that there are so few of us here
about 60 MEPS so less than 10 percent of
the European Parliament listened to this
speech because it's really worth
listening to the voice of Lithuania of
the Baltic states of our region I regret
but that's the reality I am glad that we
are meeting here again because Mr
President uh
joined us in Poland during our national
holiday it was a very important visit
but I was thinking about what you will
say today Mr President and I think I
guessed correctly and I guess correctly
because I knew you would be talking
about Ukraine and thank you for this you
will be talking about history and you
will want to show Lithuania as the
country which is a part of this European
mainstream and I remember very well when
Samus the Lithuanian Parliament was the
only one and the first one which voted
unanimously
two
to adopt European Constitution which was
later rejected in referenda by the
Netherlands and France however I think
that sometimes it's worth discussing
things even arguing when it comes to
Europe because from these arguments we
can have decisions which will later be
very positive for the eel and at the end
I want to say that I believe that you
will support also polish minority in
Lithuania because this pluralism and
support for minorities is absolutely
fundamental thank you
foreign
once again we've got a speech talking
about war without looking at any other
way of solving problems people are in
more and more Dire Straits as we see
production being centralized low
salaries more precarious work and the
European Union's still failing to avoid
any solutions these are measures which
are just going to increase poverty and
concentrate wealth in fewer and fewer
hands
there's a
huge increase in the cost of living and
what we need to do is put an end to the
speculation of big economic groups and
they have seen profits we need
investment in public sectors and
show solidarity in providing social
assistance for people who need it we
need to stop exploitation and the
precarious nature of people's jobs all
these things needed are needed in Europe
and Europe is continuing to refuse to
provide them people are getting fed up
they are mobilizing at work and they're
going to demand the right to a job with
a higher salary and more rights we want
an end to exploitation they want Market
markets to be regulated and maximum
prices to be put into place they want
peace this isn't voice which you need to
be listening to thank you
for presidential Madam president Mr
President
you have said
with violence and lies
will destroy what we find valuable in
Europe
and that is true ladies and gentlemen
this brutal war of aggression against
Ukraine has brought two
points of recognition to us that we have
to rely on one another for defense in
the NATO and our defense Union is more
important than ever and secondly with
energy Supply we depend on one another
and Germany as it already as mentioned
would have been well advised in past
years
to listen to what
Estonia Latvia and Lithuania had said
and followed that advice and earlier in
Germany we said the future of the Baltic
countries is in Europe and today we say
and I say this as a German member
looking at defense at energy but above
all Mr President
this very clear orientation you've given
us means that I can say the future
orientation of Europe should be in the
Baltic
and the spirit of the Baltic way should
be leading Europe and I would like to
agree with you for saying that in fact
indeed
when we talk about the future of Europe
then people Express concerns that future
steps towards European integration would
mean less influence from the smaller
countries but I think the Baltic way
demonstrates the opposite is true
together common decisions European
decisions can prevent us from going on a
single path as individuals and I think
we're talking standing now at a
threshold and if we look at our defense
capabilities when we speak of those they
should no longer be dependent on who
happens to be in the white house we're
in front of important steps that we need
to take where we can only give one
unified European answer energy defense
you've mentioned in other other topics
and John juncker once said that we have
two kinds of member states
uh we have two we're small countries and
countries who know they're small
countries and I think it's important
recall that as a small country you can
behave as a really great country and I
think as a small member State then a
member can actually become something
great and a very
I'm very proud that Mrs metzela has come
from a small country yet is elected to
president so a small country can be
quite great indeed thank you very much
come on I give the floor now to lesek
Miller
[Applause]
I am presidential
president
Madam president dear colleagues
in the month on the 16th of April it'll
be the 20th anniversary
of signing by the governments of Poland
and Lithuania and Athens of the
accession treaty which was the legal
basis for our accession into the EU
eight other countries did the same back
then and it was the largest
enlargement in the history of the EU I
had the honor as the Polish prime
minister to sign that treaty
and both in Poland and in Lithuania I'm
sure this 20th anniversary will be an
opportunity
to sum up the years of our membership Mr
President I'm sure that you have a very
positive view of these 20 years of us
being in the EU just like myself and
many polls
however not only history is important
what is important is the discussion
about the future of Europe upholding the
ideas that keep us together
this idea was embodied in the support
for Ukraine that is facing Russian
aggression but also in the respect of
European values the rule of law
social justice
the equality of men and women
support for everyone who needs it and
expect it
we are able to renew ourselves to build
Bridges this is the right path and we
need to continue along that path
thinking about the future Generations
we need to be even more integrated in
the EU
and we need to respect all the values
due to which we have gathered here all
together I am convinced that both
Lithuania and all the other members
States will be following that path thank
you for one minute
their chair and their president noseda
very welcome to our house and you
referred to Summer 21 by lukashenko
brutally instrumentalized migrants by
sending them to your border the EU stood
behind your country as it was an attack
on the EU and also an attack on our
values
but the only right response is a
value-based one the court of justice
last summer was crystal clear
lithuania's legislation allowing for
pushbacks automatic detention and denial
of the right to Asylum is illegal under
EU law
and despite this your government
approved the bill further legalizing
these illegal policies and we hear your
government justify these violations
under the misguided arguments of
fighting instrumentalization but what
you do is fighting innocent victims in
need of protection
so I urge you to stop these pushbacks
and arbitrary detentions and to adjust
the legislation in line with the court
of justice ruling
don't turn away refugees at the border
but turn away from unlawful policies
restore the rule of law at the eu's
borders defend EU values and we will
stand with you thank you thank you Miss
trick I give the floor now to Carlo
wrestler for two minutes
president
thank you president president
colleagues together with our Baltic
neighbors uh Lithuania Ukraine but also
Croatia my country has fought against
repression has fought for freedom has
tried to preserve its identity its
language and its culture all of this
while our freedom was not taken for
granted may it was contested by many
especially by stronger and larger
neighbors Croatia and Ukraine have
suffered aggression Croatia managed to
defend itself to free itself and we know
very well what Ukraine is going through
years of well-prepared aggression uh
strong propaganda but also well
orchestrated internal Rebellion this is
something that Ukraine is now living
through and Croatia has the has this in
its past
maybe the same was being prepared for
the Baltic states as well the Baltic
states have felt the impact of
misinformation in the past decade they
felt impact on its digital
infrastructure Ukraine suffers many
attacks on its civil civilian
infrastructure great Asia is Far From
Any military danger at this moment but
still we have many cultural attacks
going on although we are quite different
and we are at different moments in
history we have one thing in common we
know who we are we know what our values
are and we know where we belong and for
these reasons it is most important that
every corner of Europe regardless of how
far we feel we are from any kind of war
or any kind of front it is important to
know that it is our future that is being
decided in Ukraine today plot to Isabel
Santos now and can I please ask the
colleagues who are coming into the room
now to keep it quiet Isabel go ahead
Mr President now said let me Begin by
expressing my recognition for the brave
determined way that Lithuania has stood
up for European values in the face of
autocratic regimes not just Putin and
lukashenka but also
other forces it's an example for many
countries in the European Union but
I
would
say that I have been in Lithuania and
I've seen the unpleasant conditions that
immigrants from Africa and the Middle
East have been subjected to having been
used by lukashenka as
weapons
a lot of these people have been freed
and the conditions have improved we're
aware of that but medicine Frontier have
been forced to abandon their operations
there because of restrictions imposed
upon them
and in 2022 more than 8 000 uzbeks have
been sent to the Lithuanian border as
well who are continuing to appear
so Mr President violations of human
rights violations of international law
can't be combated with more human rights
violations of international or european
law I'm sure that they all show the same
level of humanity that you've shown to
those refugees from Ukraine
now to Mr olekas once again I asked the
colleagues please to keep it quiet once
they come into the room
thank you chairman president dear
colleagues I am proud to be a
representative of Lithuania
president you mentioned
our glorious history but I'd like to
focus on the last years 18 years since
we are members of the EU the move
forward has been gigantic in terms of
GDP it's almost at the level of the EU
average we are full-fledged members of
the EU and NATO
we faced a lot of challenges during the
last years covid-19 the stolen election
by the Bella Russian
dictator and last but not least the
Russian war against Ukraine you're
excellently I would like to thank you
for your personal efforts for
consolidating the support to Ukraine and
I'd like to take this opportunity to
thank the Lithuanian people who have
received a lot of refugees from Ukraine
we are facing discussions today and I
fully agree with you that the only
guarantee for peace is kicking out the
occupants occupiers from Ukraine and the
special Tribunal
for the criminals as well as a
full-fledged membership for Ukraine in
the European Union
you mentioned not only the Russian
dictator but also the Bell the Russian
one
almost 1 500 political prisoners are in
Belarus in in human conditions and
therefore I'd like to request the
European Council together with the
European Parliament encouragement
do everything that those political
presidents be released including
colesnikova statue balaski and others
in spite
of
the economic crisis sparked off by the
Russian aggression and the
thanks to the resilience and despite the
resilience of our citizens we can see
that some of
some of the sectors are profiting from
the crisis such as the banking sector
the Pharma sector and these excessive
and the energies and is excessive
profits should be reigned in
we are also seeing the importance of
securing food security and it is high
time to ensure that the European Farmers
receive equal support
and that the direct payments
reach the farmers in the Baltic
countries that we have a just in Social
Europe or is yours to answer the
questions the varying arguments points
that have been made over the past hour
the floor is yours
welcome again
first of all I would like to react to
some comments
made by
the colleagues your parliamentary
members from Lithuania for example Mr
stomachevskis regretted
that I am attacked
by some political parties in Lithuania
even
after the elections where I where I
collected 67 support
you know
I am new man in the politics I went to
the politics in 2009 19 I was elected as
a president as an independent candidate
the president of Lithuania but one issue
I realized being in the politics that
the politics is not just peaceful and
consistent with the political parties
this is a fight this is a competition
and this is not a competition for my own
interests but it's the competition for
the ideas I present and but one of the
main priorities I've been to the
politics and but my program was
dedicated to the social welfare state
idea
and even in being in this competition
this sometimes the oppositions sometimes
with ruling Coalition we were able to
implement some very important measures
which will make the life of some
sensitive and
exposable groups of society better first
of all the pensioners
socially socially affected families and
so on and so on
now uh some comments on migration I
would like to test the issue of
migration because this is very important
we have two kinds of migration migration
which is caused by just spontaneous
movements of the people from the
countries there are some social problems
those countries are in the stage of War
and this second kind of migration we
call it instrumentalized migration
and we face this phenomena into 2020.
people just became the weapons in the
hands of some totalitarian leaders
which are near to us for example Mr
lukashenka
and he used deliberately
these kind of migration
just trying to destabilize the situation
in my country and in European Union
what we need in this situation we need
very clear legal framework in order to
deal with this kind of challenges if we
will not have it
just we will put the uh the instruments
into the hands of of lukashenko or Putin
to attack us to destabilize us and this
is not good so this is the reason why we
ask European Parliament we ask a
European commission to provide this kind
of legal framework in order to be more
efficient and in order to be more
successful in fighting illegal migration
of course not this is not only one issue
there are many other issues and we have
we have to strengthen our strategic
communication
we have to help these people which
returned to the origin countries to be
reintegrated into the society and we
have much to be much more active in the
countries of origin of migration and
Transit of migration
now about Ukraine
while listening is taking the lead in
providing the support to Ukraine I can
explain it by telling you some historic
facts there was a time 14 15 16th
century as we there in the same same
Commonwealth Commonwealth of lithuanians
coexisting
with
belarusians and ukrainians and it was
very peaceful formation
of the countries one a common body of
countries
and there was full respect of the
Nations to each other even
the Nations which belong to different
language groups they have very different
traditions and you know these kind of
feelings we remember
lead to the empathy to Ukraine we treat
them like the brothers and sisters they
are our brothers and sisters the second
reason
Lithuania s never one else probably
maybe multi countries in Poland putting
them together
understands that the fight
in the battle on the battlefields in
Ukraine
is this Freedom fight but not only the
freedom fighter of ukrainians this is
our freedom fight
because as my colleague I think from
Estonia mentioned
the second target will be
multi-countries Poland maybe Romania and
this will be third target if Putin will
be not stopped in Ukraine there will be
next targets we have to be fully aware
of it
China
yes Lithuania had some
interesting challenging
story history of relations with China
several years ago we decided to leave
so-called format of 17 plus one
because we realize that this format is
not any
much promising to us and implementing a
very important infrastructure projects
and so on and so on
and we decided to leave it and we still
defend the idea that we have to speak
with China One Voice
so 27 countries plus one would be best
suitable format in communication and
relations with China
some other countries followed our
example and now this format is already
13 or 14 plus one and I think that
sooner or later we will come to the
conclusion that the best way or to deal
with China is just 27 plus one
uh
enlargement of European Union this is
very important and we are Keen proponent
of enlargement of Europe the defend the
right of our Nations to join European
Union sooner or later so this is the
reason why we support the aspirations of
Moldova aspirations of Ukraine
aspirations of Georgia because we
remember very well
what the trigger powerful trigger of
progress was our membership in European
Union as we entered the European Union
we started from
43 of GTP per capita now we already
reached 86 percent of GDP per capita and
we are running forward
with excellent speed
so this is a huge opportunity to be
European but this is also responsibility
to be European means responsibility to
be sensible
to be United and to help
the countries in need and this country
in need is now Ukraine so we have to
understand and remember it very well
thank you
[Applause]
Mr President thank you the sitting will
resume in approximately one minute where
we start with the votes
so going to the votes we start with the
report by Mr halitsky before we start
with the robot by misalisky your
colleague you want to make a point of
order
go ahead